The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So.
In the meantime, you've started
looking at two phase
equilibrium.
So now we're starting
to look at mixtures.
And so now we have more
than one constituent.
And we have more than
one phase present.
Right?
So you've started to look at
things that look like this,
where you've got, let's
say, two components.
Both in the gas phase.
And now to try to figure
out what the phase
equilibria look like.
Of course it's now a little bit
more complicated than what
you went through before, where
you can get pressure
temperature phase diagrams with
just a single component.
Now we want to worry about
what's the composition.
Of each of the components.
In each of the phases.
And what's the temperature
and the pressure.
Total and partial pressures
and all of that.
So you can really figure out
everything about both phases.
And there are all sorts of
important reasons to do that,
obviously lots of chemistry
happens in liquid mixtures.
Some in gas mixtures.
Some where they're
in equilibrium.
All sorts of chemical
processes.
Distillation, for example,
takes advantage of the
properties of liquid
and gas mixtures.
Where one of them might be
richer, will be richer, and
the more volatile of
the components.
That can be used as a basis
for purification.
You mix ethanol and water
together so you've got a
liquid with a certain
composition of each.
The gas is going to be richer
and the more volatile of the
two, the ethanol.
So in a distillation, where you
put things up in the gas,
more of the ethanol comes up.
You could then collect
that gas, right?
And re-condense it, and
make a new liquid.
Which is much richer in ethanol
than the original
liquid was.
Then you could make, then you
could put some of them up into
the gas phase.
Where it will be still
richer in ethanol.
And then you could collect that
and repeat the process.
So the point is that properties
of liquid gas,
two-component or multi-component
mixtures like
this can be exploited.
Basically, the different
volatilities of the different
components can be exploited for
things like purification.
Also if you want to calculate
chemical equilibria in the
liquid and gas phase, of
course, now you've seen
chemical equilibrium, so the
amount of reaction depends on
the composition.
So of course if you want
reactions to go, then this
also can be exploited by looking
at which phase might
be richer in one reactant
or another.
And thereby pushing the
equilibrium toward one
direction or the other.
OK.
So. we've got some total
temperature and pressure.
And we have compositions.
So in the gas phase, we've got
mole fractions yA and yB.
In the liquid phase we've got
mole fractions xA and xB.
So that's our system.
One of the things that you
established last time is that,
so there are the total number
of variables including the
temperature and the pressure.
And let's say the mole fraction
of A in each of the
liquid and gas phases, right?
But then there are
constraints.
Because the chemical
potentials have
to be equal, right?
Chemical potential of
A has to be equal in
the liquid and gas.
Same with B. Those two
constraints reduce the number
of independent variables.
So there'll be two in this
case rather than four
independent variables.
If you control those, then
everything else will follow.
What that means is if you've got
a, if you control, if you
fix the temperature and the
total pressure, everything
else should be determinable.
No more free variables.
And then, what you saw is that
in simple or ideal liquid
mixtures, a result called
Raoult's law would hold.
Which just says that the partial
pressure of A is equal
to the mole fraction of A in the
liquid times the pressure
of pure A over the liquid.
And so what this gives
you is a diagram
that looks like this.
If we plot this versus xB, this
is mole fraction of B in
the liquid going from
zero to one.
Then we could construct a
diagram of this sort.
So this is the total pressure
of A and B. The partial
pressures are given
by these lines.
So this is our pA star
and pB star.
The pressures over the pure
liquid A and B at the limits
of mole fraction of B
being zero and one.
So in this situation, for
example, A is the more
volatile of the components.
So it's partial pressure
over its pure liquid.
At this temperature.
Is higher than the partial
pressure of B
over its pure liquid.
A would be the ethanol, for
example and B the water in
that mixture.
OK.
Then you started looking at both
the gas and the liquid
phase in the same diagram.
So this is the mole fraction
of the liquid.
If you look and see, well, OK
now we should be able to
determine the mole fraction
in the gas as well.
Again, if we note total
temperature and pressure,
everything else must follow.
And so, you saw this
worked out.
Relation between p and
yA, for example.
The result was p is pA star
times pB star over pA star
plus pB star minus
pA star times yA.
And the point here is that
unlike this case, where you
have a linear relationship, the
relationship between the
pressure and the liquid mole
fraction isn't linear.
We can still plot
it, of course.
So if we do that, then we end
up with a diagram that looks
like the following.
Now I'm going to keep both mole
fractions, xB and yB,
I've got some total pressure.
I still have my linear
relationship.
And then I have a non-linear
relationship between the
pressure and the mole fraction
in the gas phase.
So let's just fill this in.
Here is pA star still.
Here's pB star.
Of course, at the limits they're
still, both mole
fractions they're zero and one.
OK.
I believe this is this is where
you ended up at the end
of the last lecture.
But it's probably not so clear
exactly how you read
something like this.
And use it.
It's extremely useful.
You just have to kind of learn
how to follow what happens in
a diagram like this.
And that's what I want to spend
some of today doing.
Is just, walking through what's
happening physically,
with a container with a
mixture of the two.
And how does that correspond
to what gets read off the
diagram under different
conditions.
So.
Let's just start somewhere on
a phase diagram like this.
Let's start up here at some
point one, so we're in the
pure - well, not pure, you're
in the all liquid phase.
It's still a mixture.
It's not a pure substance.
pA star, pB star.
There's the gas phase.
So, if we start at one, and now
there's some total pressure.
And now we're going
to reduce it.
What happens?
We start with a pure - with
an all-liquid mixture.
No gas.
And now we're going to bring
down the pressure.
Allowing some of the liquid to
go up into the gas phase.
So, we can do that.
And once we reach point
two, then we find
a coexistence curve.
Now the liquid and gas
are going to coexist.
So this is the liquid phase.
And that means that
this must be xB.
And it's xB at one, but it's
also xB at two, and I want to
emphasize that.
So let's put our pressure
for two.
And if we go over here, this is
telling us about the mole
fraction in the gas phase.
That's what these curves
are, remember.
So this is the one that's
showing us the mole fraction
in the liquid phase.
This nonlinear one
in the gas phase.
So that means just reading off
it, this is xB, that's the
liquid mole fraction.
Here's yB.
The gas mole fraction.
They're not the same, right,
because of course the
components have different
volatility.
A's more volatile.
So that means that the mole
fraction of B in the liquid
phase is higher than the
mole fraction of
B in the gas phase.
Because A is the more
volatile component.
So more, relatively more, of A,
the mole fraction of A is
going to be higher up
in the gas phase.
Which means the mole
fraction of B is
lower in the gas phase.
So, yB less than xB if
A is more volatile.
OK, so now what's happening
physically?
Well, we started at a
point where we only
had the liquid present.
So at our initial pressure,
we just have all liquid.
There's some xB at one.
That's all there is, there
isn't any gas yet.
Now, what happened here?
Well, now we lowered
the pressure.
So you could imagine, well,
we made the box bigger.
Now, if the liquid was under
pressure, being squeezed by
the box, right then you
could make the box
a little bit bigger.
And there's still no gas.
That's moving down like this.
But then you get to a point
where there's just barely any
pressure on top of the liquid.
And then you keep expanding
the box.
Now some gas is going to form.
So now we're going to
go to our case two.
We've got a bigger box.
And now, right around
where this was, this
is going to be liquid.
And there's gas up here.
So up here is yB at
pressure two.
Here's xB at pressure two.
Liquid and gas.
So that's where we are
at point two here.
Now, what happens if
we keep going?
Let's lower the pressure
some more.
Well, we can lower
it and do this.
But really if we want to see
what's happening in each of
the phases, we have to stay
on the coexistence curves.
Those are what tell us what
the pressures are.
What the partial pressure
are going to be
in each of the phases.
In each of the two, in the
liquid and the gas phases.
So let's say we lower the
pressure a little more.
What's going to happen
is, then we'll end up
somewhere over here.
In the liquid, and that'll
correspond to something over
here in the gas.
So here's three.
So now we're going to have,
that's going to be xB at
pressure three.
And over here is going to
be yB at pressure three.
And all we've done, of
course, is we've just
expanded this further.
So now we've got a
still taller box.
And the liquid is going to be a
little lower because some of
it has evaporated, formed
the gas phase.
So here's xB at three.
Here's yB at three, here's
our gas phase.
Now we could decrease
even further.
And this is the sort of
thing that you maybe
can't do in real life.
But I can do on a blackboard.
I'm going to give myself more
room on this curve, to finish
this illustration.
There.
Beautiful.
So now we can lower a little bit
further, and what I want
to illustrate is, if we keep
going down, eventually we get
to a pressure where now if we
look over in the gas phase,
we're at the same pressure,
mole fraction that we had
originally in the
liquid phase.
So let's make four even
lower pressure.
What does that mean?
What it means is, we're
running out of liquid.
So what's supposed to
happen is A is the
more volatile component.
So as we start opening up some
room for gas to form, you get
more of A in the gas phase.
But of course, and the liquid is
richer in B. But of course,
eventually you run
out of liquid.
You make the box pretty big, and
you run out, or you have
the very last drop of liquid.
So what's the mole fraction
of B in the gas phase?
It has to be the same as
what it started in
in the liquid phase.
Because after all the total
number of moles of A and B
hasn't changed any.
So if you take them all from the
liquid and put them all up
into the gas phase, it
must be the same.
So yB of four.
Once you just have
the last drop.
So then yB of four is basically
equal to xB of one.
Because everything's now
up in the gas phase.
So in principle, there's still
a tiny, tiny bit of xB at
pressure four.
Well, we could keep lowering
the pressure.
We could make the box
a little bigger.
Then the very last of the liquid
is going to be gone.
And what'll happen then
is, we're all here.
There's no more liquid.
We're not going down on the
coexistence curve any more.
We don't have a liquid gas
coexistence any more.
We just have a gas phase.
Of course, we can continue
to lower the pressure.
And then what we're doing
is just going down here.
So there's five.
And five is the same as
this only bigger.
And so forth.
OK, any questions about
how this works?
It's really important to just
gain facility in reading these
things and seeing, OK, what is
it that this is telling you.
And you can see it's not
complicated to do it, but it
takes a little bit of practice.
OK.
Now, of course, we could do
exactly the same thing
starting from the gas phase.
And raising the pressure.
And although you may anticipate
that it's kind of
pedantic, I really do want to
illustrate something by it.
So let me just imagine that
we're going to do that.
Let's start all in
the gas phase.
Up here's the liquid.
pA star, pB star.
And now let's start
somewhere here.
So we're down somewhere in
the gas phase with some
composition.
So it's the same story, except
now we're starting here.
It's all gas.
And we're going to
start squeezing.
We're increasing the pressure.
And eventually here's one, will
reach two, so of course
here's our yB.
We started with all
gas, no liquid.
So this is yB of one.
It's the same as yB of two, I'm
just raising the pressure
enough to just reach the
coexistence curve.
And of course, out here tells
us xB of two, right?
So what is it saying?
We've squeezed and started
to form some liquid.
And the liquid is richer in
component B. Maybe it's
ethanol water again.
And we squeeze, and now we've
got more water in the liquid
phase than in the gas phase.
Because water's the less
volatile component.
It's what's going to
condense first.
So the liquid is rich in the
less volatile of the
components.
Now, obviously, we can continue
in doing exactly the
reverse of what I showed you.
But all I want to really
illustrate is, this is a
strategy for purification of the
less volatile component.
Once you've done this, well now
you've got some liquid.
Now you could collect that
liquid in a separate vessel.
So let's collect the liquid
mixture with xB of two.
So it's got some mole fraction
of B. So we've purified that.
But now we're going to start,
we've got pure liquid.
Now let's make the vessel big.
So it all goes into
the gas phase.
Then lower p.
All gas.
So we start with yB of three,
which equals xB of two.
In other words, it's the
same mole fraction.
So let's reconstruct that.
So here's p of two.
And now we're going to go
to some new pressure.
And the point is, now we're
going to start, since the mole
fraction in the gas phase that
we're starting from is the
same number as this was.
So it's around here somewhere.
That's yB of three
equals xB of two.
And we're down here.
In other words, all we've done
is make the container big
enough so the pressure's low and
it's all in the gas phase.
That's all we have,
is the gas.
But the composition is whatever
the composition is
that we extracted here
from the liquid.
So this xB, which is the liquid
mole fraction, is now
yB, the gas mole fraction.
Of course, the pressure
is different.
Lower than it was before.
Great.
Now let's increase.
So here's three.
And now let's increase
the pressure to four.
And of course what happens,
now we've got coexistence.
So here's liquid.
Here's gas.
So, now we're over here again.
There's xB at pressure four.
Pure still in component B. We
can repeat the same procedure.
Collect it.
All liquid, put it
in a new vessel.
Expand it, lower the pressure,
all goes back
into the gas phase.
Do it all again.
And the point is, what you're
doing is walking along here.
Here to here.
Then you start down here, and
go from here to here.
From here to here.
And you can purify.
Now, of course, the optimal
procedure, you have to think a
little bit.
Because if you really do
precisely what I said, you're
going to have a mighty little
bit of material
each time you do that.
So yes it'll be the little bit
you've gotten at the end is
going to be really pure, but
there's not a whole lot of it.
Because, remember, what we
said is let's raise the
pressure until we just
start being on
the coexistence curve.
So we've still got mostly gas.
Little bit of liquid.
Now, I could raise the pressure
a bit higher.
So that in the interest of
having more of the liquid,
when I do that, though, the
liquid that I have at this
higher pressure won't be as
enriched as it was down here.
Now, I could still do
this procedure.
I could just do more of them.
So it takes a little bit of
judiciousness to figure out
how to optimize that.
In the end, though, you can
continue to walk your way down
through these coexistence curves
and purify repeatedly
the component B, the less
volatile of them, and end up
with some amount of it.
And there'll be some balance
between the amount that you
feel like you need to end
up with and how pure
you need it to be.
Any questions about
how this works?
So purification of less
volatile components.
Now, how much of each of
these quantities in
each of these phases?
So, pertinent to this
discussion, of course we need
to know that.
If you want to try to optimize
a procedure like that, of
course it's going to be
crucial to be able to
understand and calculate for any
pressure that you decide
to raise to, just how many moles
do you have in each of
the phases?
So at the end of the day, you
can figure out, OK, now when I
reach a certain degree of
purification, here's how much
of the stuff I end up with.
Well, that turns out
to be reasonably
straightforward to do.
And so what I'll go through
is a simple mathematical
derivation.
And it turns out that it allows
you to just read right
off the diagram how much of each
material you're going to
end up with.
So, here's what happens.
This is something called
the lever rule.
How much of each component
is there in each phase?
So let's consider a
case like this.
Let me draw yet once again,
just to get the numbering
consistent.
With how we'll treat this.
So we're going to start here.
And I want to draw it right
in the middle, so I've
got plenty of room.
And we're going to go
up to some pressure.
And somewhere out there,
now I can go to
my coexistence curves.
Liquid.
And gas.
And I can read off my values.
So this is the liquid xB.
So I'm going to go up to some
point two, here's xB of two.
Here's yB of two.
Great.
Now let's get these
written in.
So let's just define terms
a little bit. nA, nB.
Or just our total number of
moles. ng and n liquid, of
course, total number of moles.
In the gas and liquid phases.
So let's just do the calculation
for each
of these two cases.
We'll start with one.
That's the easier case.
Because then we have
only the gas.
So at one, all gas.
It says pure gas in the notes,
but of course that
isn't the pure gas.
It's the mixture of the
two components.
So.
How many moles of A?
Well it's the mole fraction
of A in the gas.
Times the total number
of moles in the gas.
Let me put one in here.
Just to be clear.
And since we have all gas, the
number of moles in the gas is
just the total number
of moles.
So this is just yA at
one times n total.
Let's just write that in.
And of course n total is
equal to nA plus nB.
So now let's look at
condition two.
Now we have to look a little
more carefully.
Because we have a liquid
gas mixture.
So nA is equal to yA
at pressure two.
Times the number of moles
of gas at pressure two.
Plus xA, at pressure two, times
the number of moles of
liquid at pressure two.
Now, of course, these things
have to be equal.
The total number of moles of
A didn't change, right?
So those are equal.
Then yA of two times
ng of two.
Plus xA of two times n liquid of
two, that's equal to yA of
one times n total.
Which is of course equal to yA
of one times n gas at two plus
n liquid at two.
I suppose I could be,
add that equality.
Of course, it's an
obvious one.
But let me do it anyway.
The total number of moles
is equal to nA plus nB.
But it's also equal to
n liquid plus n gas.
And that's all I'm taking
advantage of here.
And now I'm just going to
rearrange the terms.
So I'm going to write yA at one
minus yA at two, times ng
at two, is equal to, and I'm
going to take the other terms,
the xA term. xA of two
minus yA of one
times n liquid at two.
So I've just rearranged
the terms.
And I've done that because
now, I think I omitted
something here. yA
of one times ng.
No, I forgot a bracket, is what
I did. yA of one there.
And I did this because now I
want to do is look at the
ratio of liquid to gas
at pressure two.
So, ratio of I'll put it gas
to liquid, that's ng of two
over n liquid at two.
And that's just equal to xA of
two minus yA at one minus yA
at one minus yA at two.
So what does it mean?
It's the ratio of these
lever arms.
That's what it's telling me.
I can look, so I raise the
pressure up to two.
And so here's xB at two,
here's yB at two.
And I'm here somewhere.
And this little amount and this
little amount, that's
that difference.
And it's just telling me that
ratio of those arms is the
ratio of the total number of
moles of gas to liquid.
And that's great.
Because now when I go back to
the problem that we were just
looking at, where I say, well
I'm going to purify the less
volatile component by raising
the pressure until I'm at
coexistence starting
in the gas phase.
Raise the pressure, I've
got some liquid.
But I also want some finite
amount of liquid.
But I don't want to just, when
I get the very, very first
drop of liquid now collected, of
course it's enriched in the
less volatile component.
But there may be a minuscule
amount, right?
So I'll raise the pressure
a bit more.
I'll go up in pressure.
And now, of course, when I do
that the amount of enrichment
of the liquid isn't as big as it
was if I just raised it up
enough to barely have
any liquid.
Then I'd be out here.
But I've got more material in
the liquid phase to collect.
And that's what this allows
me to calculate.
Is how much do I
get in the end.
So it's very handy.
You can also see, if I go all
the way to the limit where the
mole fraction in the liquid at
the end is equal to what it
was in the gas when I started,
what that says is that there's
no more gas left any more.
In other words, these two
things are equal.
If I go all the way to the point
where I've got all the,
this is the amount I started
with, in the pure gas phase,
now I keep raising
it all the way.
Until I've got the same mole
fraction in the liquid.
Of course, we know what
that really means.
That means that I've gone
all the way from
pure gas to pure liquid.
And the mole fraction in that
case has to be the same.
And what this is just telling
us mathematically is, when
that happens this is zero.
That means I don't have
any gas left.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
Because, so it's the mole
fraction in the gas phase.
But you've started with some
amount that it's only going to
go down from there.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
OK.
Well, now what I want to do
is just put up a slightly
different kind of diagram, but
different in an important way.
Namely, instead of showing the
mole fractions as a function
of the pressure.
And I haven't written it in,
but all of these are at
constant temperature, right?
I've assumed the temperature
is constant
in all these things.
Now let's consider the other
possibility, the other simple
possibility, which is, let's
hold the pressure constant and
vary the temperature.
Of course, you know in the lab,
that's usually what's
easiest to do.
Now, unfortunately, the
arithmetic gets more
complicated.
It's not monumentally
complicated, but here in this
case, where you have one linear
relationship, which is
very convenient.
From Raoult's law.
And then you have one non-linear
relationship there
for the mole fraction
of the gas.
In the case of temperature,
they're both,
neither one is linear.
Nevertheless, we can just
sketch what the
diagram looks like.
And of course it's very useful
to do that, and see how to
read off it.
And I should say the derivation
of the curves isn't
particularly complicated.
It's not particularly more
complicated than what I think
you saw last time
to derive this.
There's no complicated
math involved.
But the point is, the derivation
doesn't yield a
linear relationship for either
the gas or the liquid part of
the coexistence curve.
OK, so we're going to look at
temperature and mole fraction
phase diagrams.
Again, a little more complicated
mathematically but
more practical in real use.
And this is T. And here is the,
sort of, form that these
things take.
So again, neither
one is linear.
Up here, now, of course if you
raise the temperatures, that's
where you end up with gas.
If you lower the temperature,
you
condense and get the liquid.
So, this is TA star.
TB star.
So now I want to stick
with A as the
more volatile component.
At constant temperature, that
meant that pA star is bigger
than pB star.
In other words, the vapor
pressure over pure liquid A is
higher than the vapor pressure
over pure liquid B. Similarly,
now I've got constant pressure
and really what I'm looking
at, let's say I'm at the
limit where I've
got the pure liquid.
Or the pure A. And now I'm going
to, let's say, raise the
temperature until I'm at the
liquid-gas equilibrium.
That's just the boiling point.
So if A is the more volatile
component, it has the lower
boiling point.
And that's what this reflects.
So higher pB star A corresponds
to lower TA star
A. Which is just the boiling
point of pure A.
So, this is called
the bubble line.
That's called the dew line.
All that means is, let's say
I'm at high temperature.
I've got all gas.
Right no coexistence,
no liquid yet.
And I start to cool
things off.
Just to where I just barely
start to get liquid.
What you see that as is,
dew starts forming.
A little bit of condensation.
If you're outside, it means on
the grass a little bit of dew
is forming.
Similarly, if I start at low
temperature, all liquid now I
start raising the temperature
until I just start to boil.
I just start to see the
first bubbles forming.
And so that's why these things
have those names.
So now let's just follow along
what happens when I do the
same sort of thing that
I illustrated there.
I want to start at one point
in this phase diagram.
And then start changing
the conditions.
So let's start here.
So I'm going to start all
in the liquid phase.
That is, the temperature
is low.
Here's xB.
And my original temperature.
Now I'm going to raise it.
So if I raise it a little bit,
I reach a point at which I
first start to boil.
Start to find some gas
above the liquid.
And if I look right here,
that'll be my composition.
Let me raise it a little
farther, now that we've
already seen the lever
rule and so forth.
I'll raise it up to here.
And that means that out here,
I suppose I should do here.
So, here is the liquid mole
fraction at temperature two.
xB at temperature two.
This is yB at temperature two.
The gas mole fraction.
So as you should expect, what's
going to happen here is
that the gas, this is going to
be lower in B. A, that means
that the mole fraction
of A must be
higher in the gas phase.
That's one minus yB.
So xA is one minus -- yA, which
is one minus yB higher
in gas phase.
Than xA, which is
one minus xB.
In other words, the less
volatile component is enriched
up in the gas phase.
Now, what does that mean?
That means I could follow the
same sort of procedure that I
indicated before when we looked
at the pressure mole
fraction phase diagram.
Namely, I could do this
and now I could
take the gas phase.
Which has less of B. It
has more of A. And
I can collect it.
And then I can reduce
the temperature.
So it liquefies.
So I can condense it,
in other words.
So now I'm going to start with,
let's say I lower the
temperature enough so I've got
basically pure liquid.
But its composition is the
same as the gas here.
Because of course that's what
that liquid is formed from.
I collected the gas
and separated it.
So now I could start
all over again.
Except instead of being here,
I'll be down here.
And then I can raise the
temperature again.
To some place where I choose.
I could choose here, and
go all the way to hear.
A great amount of enrichment.
But I know from the lever rule
that if I do that, I'm going
to have precious little
material over here.
So I might prefer to raise the
temperature a little more.
Still get a substantial
amount of enrichment.
And now I've got, in the gas
phase, I'll further enriched
in component A. And again
I can collect the gas.
Condense it.
Now I'm out here somewhere, I've
got all liquid and I'll
raise the temperature again.
And I can again keep walking
my way over.
And that's what happens during
an ordinary distillation.
Each step of the distillation
walks along in the phase
diagram at some selected
point.
And of course what you're
doing is, you're always
condensing the gas.
And starting with fresh liquid
that now is enriched in more
volatile of the components.
So of course if you're really
purifying, say, ethanol from
an ethanol water mixture,
that's how you do it.
Ethanol is the more volatile
component.
So a still is set up.
It will boil the stuff and
collect the gas and and
condense it.
And boil it again,
and so forth.
And the whole thing can be set
up in a very efficient way.
So you have essentially
continuous distillation.
Where you have a whole sequence
of collection and
condensation and reheating
and so forth events.
So then, in a practical way,
it's possible to walk quite
far along the distillation,
the coexistence curve, and
distill to really a high
degree of purification.
Any questions about
how that works?
OK.
I'll leave till next time the
discussion of the chemical
potentials.
But what we'll do, just to
foreshadow a little bit, what
I'll do at the beginning of the
next lecture is what's at
the end of your notes here.
Which is just to say OK, now
if we look at Raoult's law,
it's straightforward to say what
is the chemical potential
for each of the substances in
the liquid and the gas phase.
Of course, it has to be equal.
Given that, that's for
an ideal solution.
We can gain some insight
from that.
And then look at real
solutions, non-ideal
solutions, and understand a lot
of their behavior as well.
Just from starting from our
understanding of what the
chemical potential does even
in a simple ideal mixture.
So we'll look at the chemical
potentials.
And then we'll look at
non-ideal solution
mixtures next time.
See you then.